everything alright miss what's your name  I don't know what is your address oh no  how about your birthday I don't know  we're trying to understand what happened  to you I knew something was wrong with  me but I couldn't explain it to anyone I  was like the people around me were  keeping a secret  like we were in a movie  and everyone knew we were in a movie  except for me if I did something wrong I  have no idea what it is the complaints  been elevated there's going to be an  investigation was hard for me to come  down here okay there's no one I can it's  hard for me to talk about this I'm sorry  Jesus well you went to here I don't know  to think this is all critical military  technology they're in charge here  whether we like it or not then you like  it what was i doing why was I be  it's complicated  how did we get here what we did no good  can come of that what if we let the  crazy world if you keep picking at this  it's gonna start bleeding  you